We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. I got a bunch of voicemails in the
last 24 hours accusing me of deep platforming,
fellow progressive host Sam Cedar.
Like I don't even understand what they're
talking about.
Listen to this.
What up?
GP, longtime fan here.
I've been listening to you before you hit
puberty, was listening to you when you came
out that you weren't gay.
Quite sad about that actually.
But I'm actually calling, kind of upset you,
the platform, my boy Sam Cedar, and we need
to figure out what, why, why platform.
Yeah.
So I'm hoping you're willing to address that
situation of the platform.
And Sam Cedar, this is Jason from the seven
oh seven.
I don't know what this guy's talking about.
And here's another one.
Hey, David, I don't know if
you saw the, uh, Sam Cedar show today, but
he totally talked about you.
You said that you are a by not showing his
entire clip.
You totally d platformed and bro.
So thank you.
Should totally respond to that.
And uh, then we'll see what Sam has to say
to defend himself against your a platforming.
Keep up the fight.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean, listen, I think that this is maybe
someone coming to tattle to me about Sam seaters
responds to, to someone else tattling, tattling
or the, at this point it's like a endless,
uh, it, it's, it's like those Russian Matryoshka
dolls.
I don't know how else to describe it.
I don't know what is going on.
I don't know anything about d platforming,
Sam Cedar.
I don't know what these people are talking
about, but I will try to check out that clip.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about the new New York City tenant
law that has landlords very, very fired up.
I also want to talk about a division within
the Democratic Party about whether they should
give themselves the 2.6% cost of living raise
that they are due in January.
Uh, and I also want to talk about Ted Cruz
apparently wants to team up with Alexandria.
Casteo court tends to make a birth control
available over the counter, but this is actually
a stealth free market.
Conservative move doesn't mean we should oppose
it.
If it's the right thing to make birth control
available over the counter without a prescription,
then it should be.
But I do want to explain to you what Ted Cruz
is.
Ulterior motives are because they are exactly
what you would imagine them to be.
Get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member at
www dot join [inaudible] dot com or become
a patron at patrion.com/david Packard